take a look at
that oh
wow Asher graffiti artist skid R Los
angelist
2020 I'm going to be confronted by
somebody in a negative way and I know
and understand this this is a risk I'm
willing to take whether it's an 18th
Street gang member telling me this is
his territory or security guard or a
police officer a business owner another
graffiti Rider anybody I'm going to run
into one of them guaranteed but that's
what separates me I don't run ever I own
that and so when somebody confronts
you not only do they not understand why
you're not running but they respect you
for that even if it's their building and
you turn and tell them why even if they
don't agree with it he's not going to
punch you in the face or shoot you
because not only
I'm I articulate and I'm telling him
exactly what I'm doing it's the first
time he's ever spoken or confronted what
he would consider a tagger or graffiti
writer and this guy's not what he
thought so my appearance and my art
looks abrasive and I totally understand
that but it's supposed to but it's a
reflection of who I am and where I'm
from that was a quote that I said from
my interview and this is a picture of my
interview um or of
me I was fat
I have a black eye two black eyes
um yeah you look rough I do look rough
and um I actually sought you out for
this interview because I had these black
eyes and I
wanted we didn't use my first interview
but I thought you know what this one not
only will he use
it but I I don't look good but that's
how how unra I was at the time that I
would want to show myself in a negative
light I guess but I didn't consider it
negative at the time because I was so
delusional um but this is extremely
powerful and uh this book wow um I asked
I asked you about this um I you remember
yeah yeah no you you were always saying
you should do a book you should do a
book because
um I don't think a lot of people know or
understand uh that you're not a
videographer no I'm just a photographer
Mark doesn't do interviews doesn't do
videos but you're world famous for doing
both um but Mark you're an amazing
photographer and these um photos and
these things that you've captured um are
unbelievable to me the stories behind
them is uh what you wanted to tell
besides the photos and I think this uh
definitely captures that for sure and um
well I learned in my first book create
equal which I did like 10 12 years ago
um it's a book of of portraits across
the United States all lower 48 and it
I'm proud of it but when people look at
it there's a million
questions photography just doesn't
answer every single question so I
realized after doing that like if I ever
do this again I got to do like something
to explain more of the story well that
the photograph just can't communicate
you definitely uh and that's what this
is not well you definitely did it but um
these photos are so
powerful to me because um not only do I
see my friends and neighbors
um
beautiful
people but I'm not going to lie and I
see the hurt and Trauma and pain in each
in every one of these and um every
single person in skid Ro is a victim of
some kind myself included and
uh your work over the last 5 years on
this book last 15 years being down here
um I never knew what you were doing uh
and what I mean I never knew what you're
were doing I mean like let me elaborate
how long are you going to continue this
like what is it going to take for you to
say okay I think I completed it well
when it comes to awareness I don't think
it's ever over you know can you ever
bring too much aware but for me
personally um I'm honored to be in this
and be a part of it but um I actually
saw Hutch review of the book didn't see
his interview because Mark I don't watch
it's not for everybody no it's not for
me because um they're too hurtful and
too painful and uh a lot of the negative
things that have happened to these
people have happened to me so to relive
those stories to them is a trigger for
me and not only that but I've mentioned
numerous times that these are my
beautiful friends and neighbors I can
know somebody for a decade or more and
never know their past history and be
completely okay with that but if I watch
your channel and I see my friend I'm
excited to hear what they have to say
until they start talking and I'm like oh
stop stop stop because now I think
about this every time I see them and I
don't want to think these things because
they're negative things not based on
them but about what they said so now
when I see my friend Quinn it's just my
friend Quinn but now after he's been on
the show I can't help think about his
childhood think about you know I always
thought that he had a
limp I didn't know he's handicapped and
he went through some very bad accident
and that it's caused him all kinds of
grief throughout his life Mark I've been
teasing that man about that
limp that that triggers him well I mean
everybody on planet earth goes through
something but very true but the thing of
it is is I think you've done an amazing
job and um this book not only am I
extremely proud to be a part of it but
um you did it you did it my friend I'm
so glad you helped me out well me too
but um this is my beautiful friend Jerry
uh rest in peace and so
misunderstood um he's probably the most
misunderstood person yeah I've
interviewed gunshot victim and he would
sit on the corner of six
in Los Angeles and kind of cover his
face and just kind of like this with and
ask for change but when he stood up he's
like almost 7 foot tall no he's like 6'5
and well 6'4 huge uh when when uh in
perspective to me he's
huge but his heart and his uh kindness
was so genuine from somebody who was the
the kindest person ever the most kindest
person you've ever met but was the
victim of the most selfless act of
violence he got shot in the face with a
shotgun for no reason and he his
kindness was something that um moved me
not only when I met him every time I saw
him and he would tell me stories he
would like you know um and I I would try
to show him things Mark he can't see
can't see he couldn't see he so he would
go like this trying to look at the phone
before I realized oh he can't see
at all he can barely cross the street
cuz he can't see what color the light is
but the story that he was telling me is
about these people who had come and
taken photos of him or done paintings
and that they were selling in galleries
for tons of money and I said how did you
know this or they had sold and he said
because somebody came and told me they
saw it or somebody can I said do those
people help you he goes no and I just
thought damn that's what the majority of
people do is come down here find the
most grotesque the most shocking images
that they can find in one weekend one
day and run off and go exploit it for
however long and um I'm just really
happy that that's not you my friend I
would not talk to you um or have any
dealings with you if you were but um I
know
that well thank you so much for being a
part of this thank you and uh I'm very
very happy you're uh a gentleman and a
scholar so are you thank you R yeah
man